hello thank you everyone for coming in
today it's wonderful to have you all
with us and this is the last keynote of
the conference this is my pleasure to
introduce you to dr. Julia pearl
he's a Chancellor's emeritus professor
at UCLA and the winner of 2011 Turing
Award also considered the Nobel Prize of
computing he's best known for
championing the probabilistic approach
to artificial intelligence and the
development of Bayesian networks so I'm
handing the mic now to Julia give him a
huge round of applause thank you thank
you can you hear me I'll try to be as
concise as possible and convey to you
the essence of my talk here in the very
first slide I have a proverb which I
composed in the cow service coming here
I think that was summarize it very
clearly my message is very simple it is
the data is a window to reality and data
science is a glass that enables us to
look through the window it is not a
mirror through which data looks at
itself under makeup that is the essence
of things which means the data science
is a two-body science connects data in
reality interpret reality in in view of
the data where you can say we all know
that so let's go and see what has been
done with data science thus far and my
outline will be one why data science
needs a new engine
to answer causal questions I call it a
new engine because for us computer
scientist a piece of software is an
engine and I call it a new engine
because it is a new organ in our mind
one that has its own logic its own
unique features the one that we haven't
even been aware that we have it like a
guy finds out one day that he has or she
has liver we can live our life without
knowing that we have a liver but once we
discover that the liver is there and its
function then it's the duty of the
physician or the physiologist understand
the function and to be able to repair it
when it goes wrong so I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk about the structure of this
new engine I don't want to keep on
saying liver and the two fundamental
laws of course influence you can look at
it as a double helix because once you
see and you acquire and you commit
yourself to these two fundamental laws
you don't have to listen to any lectures
like this one you can do everything
yourself it derive able mathematically
it's nice thing about science sometimes
you get the key and the rest is derive a
bull like the axioms of geometry and
then I'm gonna spend the second part of
my talk convincing you that it is not
just a mathematical gimmick but it has
application and I will convey the
applications through a list of seven
pillars these are tools that you will be
able to do once you acquire the double
helix and these are tools that go beyond
data science
tool that enables you to answer
questions that ordinary statistics
cannot answer it ordinary machine
learning cannot answer today they will
tomorrow and it has revolutionized data
intensive sciences from epidemiology to
economics to social science ok let's
start with the causal model and why do
we need to have one
something happens 10,000 years ago human
beings accounted for less than a tenth
of 1% of all vertebrate life on planet
Earth
and today the percentage including life
stocks increases 98% you can argue with
the numbers depend if you count chickens
or the goats but the basic fact is there
that there has been a super evolutionary
development by which human being have
were able to dominate the planet is not
in higher that something happened and
it's super evolutionary no other species
has attained this kind of global
Dominion and we haven't seen any such
transition throughout the planet life
throughout the evolutionary process its
unique so what happened well there are
many theories but the one that that
appeals to me is a computer scientists
who ask not what not what happened but
what computational facility did humans
acquire 10,000 years ago that they did
not possess before that is a secret
which we want to grab grasp and equip
machine with
and the one that appears to be most is
here this is the secret of the hummus of
Homo sapiens our ancestors which enabled
them to migrate from Africa and
essentially wipe out the Neanderthal men
in Europe and wiped out the Homo erectus
in Asia and dominate the planet what did
they have that a Neanderthal man did not
have even though physical capabilities
were in favor of the Neandertal men in
terms of size and other abilities well
look at that that is called the lion men
of state cave was found in Germany
southeast southwest Germany in a cave
and it's the first artifact that
describes an object that does not exist
in the physical world it's a combination
of the lion head in the human body you
can see it here miniaturized the ability
to imagine things that do not really
exist that was the secret by which I
didn't invent the theory it's one among
the prevalent theories of
anthropologists I took it from her
Arabic sapiens where he claims that this
ability allows men to develop larger
society how by developing a market for
promises if you can imagine things that
don't exist then I can promise you
things that do not exist and if you
trust me then we form a coherent society
that can work in unison and
villages and cities and empires and you
know where we are today larger society
working in unison because the village
elderly could offer the farmers a
promise for instance elute the the next
village that's a promise
the ruler of the country could promise
its subject protection and larger loot
if we win the battle against in the
neighboring country and the priest could
offer its parishioners you know
afterlife and all the good things that
you ever wished and that amounts to
trust at the Mount of marketing for that
the ruler required that you send your
sons and daughter to serve in his in his
harem or in his palace it's a sacrifice
that the promise made up for it so
hurrah we said it unique to human you
can teach monkeys all kind of tricks but
one thing you cannot teach monkeys is to
convince a monkey to give you a banana
by promising him limitless banana after
death in monkey heaven people do go for
that we know so it's unique to human and
it required a special computational
facility to imagine the result of the
promise the accomplishment the
fulfillment of the promise and I'm going
to cause a question that allows us not
only to engage in dreams about the
afterlife but also to do things that are
practical for instance we could answer
causal questions of the following type
how effective is a given treatment
in preventing a disease what did the new
tax break that caused our sales to go up
or our marketing campaign many of you
are engaged in electronic marketing it's
a crucial problem and what is annual
health costs of attributed to obesity it
has been in New York Times in the past
few months is it obesity that kills or
the soda can hiring records prove an
employer guilty of sex discrimination
I'm about to quit my job
will I regret it personal decision
making notice that I marked certain
verbs here in yellow and those are the
key words I can recognize them from 10
miles away I trained myself to look at
the causal attribute they define a
sentence they define a questions which
makes it uniquely part of our liver that
you cannot express in any other language
it said the language of causation
preventing coordinate of course
attribution discrimination and regret
the interesting thing about them is that
they could not be articulable in this
standard grammar of science which means
in the end until three or four decades
ago not only could not answer them he
couldn't even put them on paper he
couldn't put a paper simple facts that a
rooster crow does not call the Sun to
rise his correlation there but we know
that the Sun doesn't care about the
rooster crow the rooster crow comes
before the Sun and the highly correlated
we are all understand that it is not
this the
rooster that cause the Sun to crow and
we cannot write it down in mathematics
and if you not cannot write things down
in mathematics something happened you
can talk about it you can teach your
children about it you can convince your
friend that it's not a rooster that's
good you can convince them all in the
heuristics and in the verbal level but
you cannot combine it with data to come
be combined with data all these notions
about cause effect relation see must
have a mathematical form so you can tell
whether you have enough information to
harness the data and get quantitative
answers to for instance to what degree
that the treatment prevent a disease how
can we find from that of whether the
employer was exercising discrimination
sex discrimination in hiring can data
tell us that and how that requires
mathematics and what science has given
us unfortunately is a language which is
symmetric a language is built upon
algebra and algebra is built upon and
connective called equality sign it's
right here I put the blame on this
fellow see equality is symmetric if Y is
equal to ax then X is equal to Y over a
so the whole study of algebra you learn
in high school by which children learn
physics and geometry and optics is all
very nice but it doesn't answer the
literal the engine it doesn't allow you
to access to turn the engine of the
engine of causation and answer simple
questions like that you cannot even
articulate the question in
that language of algebra well the
replacement for that has been an arrow
for us computer scientists an arrow is
not a new animal and error is an
assignment operator it means that if we
have nature is a society of listeners
variables every variables we see around
us listen to other variables and assign
value to itself according to what eight
years for instance if I give you an
example if this microphone is at 23
degrees centigrade okay I envision that
this temperature is determined by nature
after looking at all the neighboring
variables the radiation the speed of the
molecules coming from your mouth or my
mouth
taking them into account and accordingly
assigning a value to the temperature
here is why is assigned a value
according to what nature listens and
hail from X we can have the vectors and
all these kind of things you can have
matrix but basically there is a
fundamental difference between equality
sign and the assignment operator today
we express it in a form of a graph so
the graph is nothing else but the arrow
here is simply expressing the idea the
metaphor of a society of listeners which
every variable assigned to his cell for
health evaluating to what it sees in the
neighborhood it's complex process to
determine the process of I wouldn't envy
nature from needing to decide what
temperature this microphone has
but the mere imagining that this is what
goes on in nature allows you to liberate
yourself from the handcuffs of this
equality sign which is totally symmetric
and doesn't allow you to express all
these nice verbs I'm going in now into
the ladder of causation but this this is
theoretical hierarchy
it comes from theoretical analysis of
what you can do with the arrow that you
could not do with the Equality sign it
leads to hierarchy of complexity in the
sense that you can answer question at
level I only if you have information
from level I or higher which means in
right here you have associations
statistics seeing observing astronomy
for instance hands of you cannot move
this stars and you answer questions such
as what if I see how would seeing X
change my belief in Y because your data
scientists is today and that is why I
put the robot here or level one together
with ours because this is what hours and
eagles and snakes have excelled in
developing from millions of years of
evolution an optical system that it is
and however Eagles and owls have not
developed eyeglasses no microscope or
tell us
and we did and only intent in the past
3000 years so I'm heading here and I'm
saying eh I should really aim it
climbing this ladder and be able to have
an automatic scientist the your robot
should be smart enough to become in a
way in a small world but automatic
scientist one we can invent things when
we can decide what experiment to write
at any given time to conduct and so
forth so let's go over the ladder first
Association offense level we have
Association statistics what does a
symptom tell me about a disease what
does a survey tells me about the
election results okay I see something
what you tell me about my belief of the
year that's statistics and this is data
science the way it is practiced today
the next step is to answer
interventional question for instance
what if I do it'll really the cousin of
that will be how once you know the
effect of your actions then you can
answer how do I get what I want for
instance if I take it aspirin will my
headache be over what if we burn
cigarettes cigarette you know I've never
been banned before successfully
there's no means by which we can educate
children or adults to stop smoking or
force them to do that but we can
stipulate what the effect is going to be
we can argue whether there's going to be
a black market of smuggling from Canada
and so on we can talk about it and this
is part of our part of level 2 to
stipulate the result of your actions
actions which you have not even
experienced before the next level is
counterfactuals what if I did things
differently so I actually worked and I
took an aspirin and I asked what did the
aspirin that started my headache I go
back in time I do introspection I do an
exercise of imagination like the lion
head like the lion mane and I imagine
things that do not exist
I just rerun history and Risa mule ate
my system and I asked would I be better
off with can it be alive if Oswald had
not killed him what if I had not smoked
in the past two years of fashion
equation now some people say who cares
about the past
I want to improve life here on earth so
I want to answer only intervention
equation now you do have to ask
counterfactual because got a faction mo
is a very effective language in order to
convince you to modify your software if
you would have been better off doing
acting differently then you would think
about what is it about in my software
that forced me to undo what I did and
you are the one that would knows your
software and you're the one that says
okay let me change this module and next
time I am facing
decision in the heat of soccer game I'm
going to pass to X instead of Y because
this opportunity calls for doing that
and the software piece it caused me to
pass to to Y instead of X needs to be
modified so it's a very effective way of
luring agents to change their internal
software that is a hierarchy very
important I'm surprised that before my
book book of wine came out so many
people did not know about the hierarchy
and they right I mean they say well it's
an eye-opener it's exactly what I was
facing or the way guides my thought
because I had difficulty working in
level I I didn't have information from
level I plus one keep it in mind it's
some people say it's an eye-opener for
me I can prove it you cannot do things
in level AI unless you have information
for my plus one
so it came from the mathematics it
wasn't something that was discovered by
surgery of our mind but it turns out if
the mathematics tell you they cannot do
something then it's it's a different
species it require any deed this level
has a DIF ops away this level has a
different logic than this level this is
a level of cooperation and this is the
level of intervention and this is the
level of counterfactuals they have a
different logic to them you cannot
derive the conclusions of this of these
levels from ordinary logic from standard
predicate logic now there is a new
internal semantics and
in tactics and derivation so let me go
and see an example of where the logic of
causation conflict with the logic of
correlation and the easiest way to
convince you that they the conflict
there is that one
it's Simpson paradox here the data you
might will obtain in your laboratory
when you plot a scatter plot of
cholesterol levels versus exercise so if
you look at your overall population
you'll find that the more you exercise
the higher they'll collapse you never
doesn't to jail with what we hear what
we read in the New York Times so there
is something there if you look however
in every age group you find what you
expect that the more you exercise the
lower your cholesterol level and this
Justin out of a coming because you
aggregate data that should not be
[Music]
products it exists is since what Pilsen
discovered that in 1898 but he just said
this is correlation don't pay attention
to that anyone who thinks the
correlation is causation is wrong done
however for us computer scientists it's
not done it ought to be seriously
addressed because the next question is
so which data should be trust imagine
that you are a robot you are not a New
York time reader so you have a choice
here between trusting that kind of data
or that data but some of the answers I
mean decision says we should trust its
most ascitic right is
and at the decision maker you have to
decide whether you why would you trust
that instead of that well the normal
answer is more specific is it true it
turns out it's not true we are cases
where the real answer in the correct
answer lies in the aggregate data not in
the age-specific
data not in the see specific if see the
set of covariance you can measure but
lied in the aggregate for instance if
this was the blood pressure after
treatment you will not aggregate
according to people's level of blood
pressure no you would do it if there are
many examples where it flips around so
the question what to recommend what is
the criterion what about seatbelt usage
would you classify people by the
seatbelt usage you get the wrong answer
so what it takes something beyond of the
world is a difference between seatbelt
and
doesn't change you say it again
ohm so we're so sorry oh you can you can
see it I'm a professor I teach small
classes so which where did you miss
seatbelts right well it's it's not a
theoretical discussion only it's
becoming quite practical because you
know in Europe they are talking about
legislating what they called DT RP right
opieop er that general data regulation
protection regulation yeah
which gives every individual three
rights right to know number one the
right to know whether an automatic
algorithm participated in a decision it
affects that person's life second the
right to challenge that decision and
third one the right to explanation of
why the decision was made so here's an
application hypothetical dialogue
between in a loan request and the
Machine I demand an explanation for why
my loan was denied and the answer is
because you are a female first of all
it's forbidden
because there are some attributes which
are forbidden to be even to take part in
a decision like sex religion race and so
on but aside from that let's see how
Simpsons paradox plays tricks on us here
and what if I was a male it would be
denied ooh come on so who is getting
alone here those who do not divulge the
gender this is exactly what Simpsons
paradox tells you it's you have a drug
here which is good for men good for
women but it's bad for person this is
the logic of correlation you can find in
a correlation a triplet of that nature
at a trend Oh 15 minutes I can't afford
it I'm going to go right to the seven
pillows okay but you can see the tricks
here okay the logic of correlation
accommodates it and forgives that that
it happens in a correlation domain it
doesn't happen in a causal domain it's a
different logic your intuition rebelled
against the idea that you have a drug a
magic drug that is good for men good for
women and bad for persons and that is
not derive able for common logic
definitely lost on correlation but not
even from a list Italian or boolean
logic that's something unique the logic
of causation
so it has to be incorporated in European
regulatory system correct
what is a logic the logic is built on
something very basic it is the
difference between acting and singing
and here is a simple story rain and
slippery wet seeing sprinkler on gives
you different information then turning
it on
turning it on means that you have to cut
off all the relationship between the
spring they're on a sprinkler and the
season which previously control the
sprinkler now you are telling the
sprinkler on which means you are
exercising your muscle and disabled
whatever influences made the sprinkler
on and off before you're in intervention
so it's a very simple operator by seeing
a sprinkler or I can make inference
about the season by turning it or I
cannot make influences backward that's
the basic difference so all the thing
that we learn from correlation are going
to be changed when you are doing things
so we need the calculus of doing and the
counterfactual it belongs there because
kind of factly is just doing things
after you update the history you see
pavement is slippery update what you
know about season and then you do the
surgery the I call this surgery and this
is one of the most important operators
in the new algebra of causation you take
equations away okay causation and this
is now I'm going to go to the DNA two
basic laws fundamentals if you acquire
them everything that I've done derived
by pure algebra algebra of causation so
first one is that if you have a complete
model how a variable listens to its
neighborhood you can generate all the
counterfactual
with candor factual y sub X the value of
y head x bin small x is nothing by the
solution for y in a model where you
perform the surgery
overhead easy every high school kids can
complete counterfactuals easier than he
or she can compute derive construction
in basic geometry second one is time
that you have a low of conditional
independence which means that separation
in the model the graphical separation
implies that you have conditional
independence e in the data which means
that that the model tells you allows you
to do all kind of nice things because a
connection between the causal world and
through the D separation criterion so
I'll just tell you what it enables you
to do
sing with me okay so yeah every time you
see a missing arrow in the model you
know that he's a conditioning dependence
in the data he is one big missing I can
tell you without even knowing those
functions that that that this holding
the data
C&W are independent given the separators
s in our and either tweets about collide
oh here he is another missing arrow so
you know that s and our independent okay
once you know see not W for reason that
I will skip now it's called a Collider
but once you learn that you can look at
it that if you look at the model and
decide what you ought to expect in our
data that gives you a way to go back
good from this you can do model testing
from this you can do structure learning
from this you can do you reduce
scientific question to adjustment just
what variables should I put here behind
the condition in the bar yet here behind
the condition bar so that I will be able
to get result it I want now what result
you want
engine you want to answer your query you
don't want to find the mean you don't
want to find any to find confidence
intervals this is not your question your
question is query the causal question
like that the roost of cause the Sun to
rise it's cold but now you have the
means of articulating in mathematically
right okay so ask it in the language of
counter fracture would my say our sales
go up had we exercised a different
marketing strategy
counterfactual ask it here and then
answered theoretical question whether
you can find the answer coming from any
data it is compatible with your model
turn with engine and the answer will
come out on the silver platter so this
is how it goes here is my query I want
to find the probability of the outcome
given that I do X I take an aspirin
right I need to have a assumptions in
the graph this is the person your
perception of nature engine delivers to
you a formula a formula is a recipe oh
you want this query this is your
assumptions thou shalt take the
conditional probability of Y given X and
Z in average it over Z that's a recipe
and that the estimator everything that
you learn in statistics comes after that
but first you have to express your query
honestly don't be deterred by the fact
that you have the new operator your
queries are about a new operator counter
factual and intervention ask them
honestly because you have the language
and the engine will help you translate
your language to procedures on the data
okay I'm going to go now to the pillows
this is what if you are interested to
apply them in practical domain this is
what you do if you just make one little
allowance be honest
ask your query what that's the will
create you are really interested in
estimating and second one be honest
about what you perceive to be in the
real world in the form of qualitative
who lists
to whom and this is what you can do
jumpers rate right away to confounding
contracture Algy with musician of
counterfactuals mediation analysis since
I'm out of time I will not show you the
marvelous things that you can accomplish
well then my paper and in the book okay
each one of them the result of
mathematics then gives you an algorithm
for answering those questions for
instance I want to find the external
validity sample selection vial to there
okay so allow me to go one two three
four five six seven because this is
important is it in machine learning keep
one having sent a guy to jail okay
by looking at the data and deciding and
finding out that he has the probability
one for being guilty in this case was
for it was that the client would have
been alive had he not taking the drug so
the drive manufacturer is responsible if
in the data so let me go back to what
you want to accomplish direct and
indirect effect him also important
because liability depends on direct
responsibility versus indirect
responsibility and I like this because
many in machine learning to find this
problem they pay me again and again and
no one has a solution to that just a lot
of talks yes but the machine trained in
one environment finds that environmental
condition change when and how can it a
more amortized past
turning to the new environment cockpit
and now he has to exercise in the
battlefield things have changed of
course and what can be amortized from
through this learning this problem has a
complete solution mathematically if you
only tell you what you suspect to have
changed and on the graph with areas of
suspicion and it allows you to do things
like that for instance
combined data from various sides there
is hospitals area studies each
conducting conducted and different
conditions and the different populations
and answering the questions about should
the guy go should we recommend
operations to some guy in Arkansas
how can you stipulate from from studies
diverse studies are the crazy conditions
here in a way of volunteers and this is
randomized control trial here they were
college students we know the correct
students do not act like typical members
of the population in Arkansas so how can
we put it all together and come out with
the query that really was should we
recommend operation or surgery to a guy
in Arkansas this way it's hopeless but
if you reduce it to graphs then it
becomes hopeful the specific
characteristics and the idiosyncrasies
of each study can be represented in the
graph with various gimmicks here yeah
two minutes
perfect enough for me to finish with an
anthem okay I'll get there okay once you
have it encoded in the ground
there is an algorithm that will take all
this graph put it together and answer
your query and the algorithm is is
complete and that's something that
people don't get complete means that if
it tells you no you can't do any better
you don't have enough information unless
you have a no answer you can ask so what
do I need to assume to get it through to
get the answer
the system can recommend to you if you
can only measure something that's done
between this and that and I'll be able
to answer your question okay so this is
what completeness means don't miss it so
anytime people talking about know
transfer learning this is what transfer
learning is a missing data I'm sure you
are not faced with that problem but it's
also we have a solution for that it
turned out to be a causal problem
because there are reasons why data is
missing it's not something that is in
statistics certificate doesn't tell you
why the data is missing once you
incorporate it you have a nice
algorithms and and some nice questions
I'm going so quickly look at what the
wonderful things you're gonna miss this
is not giving me another answer here no
good I finished a missing data and the
different causal discovery which I'm
going to just summarize quickly know
what asymmetry in the data gives you
hints about the structure of your model
it's growing field and I'll finish it by
saying the conclusion before people
start tomatoes it me yeah Moore has been
there about causal influence in the last
few decades and then the sum total of
everything it has been learned about it
in all prior recorded history it's a
very strong statement
but I wanted to put it because I'm not
the one who labeled this achievement to
be revolutionary it was Gary King but
doesn't even use graphs did you imagine
that from the depth of darkness he
recognized that there has been a
revolution here and I'll finish
repeating my proverb data science is a
science of interpreting reality not of
summarizing data if you take it with you
I have accomplished what I hoped for and
I would only thank co-workers my
students then short commercial the book
of Y is available it actually is not
available because it's out of start but
I brought with me ten copies I'm willing
to sign them to those who have tension
to stand in line and seriously you have
a gentle introduction to the revolution
that I described to you here Bing up
done okay
commercials done
[Applause]
I'll happy to be happy to answer any
questions
questions objections violent objections
when I have to entice you
hi my name is Christina Lerman they
actually spoke to you on Sunday at the
concert Daniel Pearl cancer Meralco and
I got this feeling that you had some
objection to natural experiments so I
wanted to give you a chance now to tell
us what you think about ability of
natural experiments to discover causal
connections and better match of
experiments how derive able from
structural equations if you have in your
model a variables that economists called
exogenous actually they don't know what
they're talking about you don't find two
economists agree on what endogeneity is
but assume that they know we're talking
about something then you can do more
than what you can do without it is
discovery right you don't need then you
can do it with additional assumptions
such as monotonicity and satisfaction of
the exclusion restrictions you can get
causal effect with randomized experiment
just based on this particular
exaggerated variable it is cover its
natural derivative of what I've been
talking about it is no need to make a
big science out of natural experiment if
you have a mother it justifies the
conclusion would be talking about then
use it but you need to know the model
first yeah oh the nice thing is the easy
camp of economies let's say we don't
need another we just stipulate that the
latter we conducted this
place in Massachusetts is a decent and
faithful lateral which mean it was
really randomized okay choosing people
to drafting people by the birthday for
instance okay it's unrelated to this we
don't have need the model well in this
case you have enough information about a
variable it was decided by randomized
experiment so incorporated into your
model but you still need to have the
exclusion restrictions exclusion that
the the IV the instrument doesn't have
direct effect over the outcome you need
to have that okay
it's in the model if you have a man if
not you assume it it's you should be
away by not writing a model you make
this as the model assumptions and
implicit they're not running away from
the need to have the conditions
expressed or exist in in reality they
are missing a lot because not having a
model for instance you can have an
instrument which is not a bad instrument
that can turn into legitimate instrument
by condition on some covariance what
covariance will allow you to turn a bad
instrument into a cautious instrument
that is a question that the graph can
tell you right away chick jack but if
you insist on ignoring your model of not
putting model explicitly your missed
opportunity so that's my answer to the
IV people in Benson company and what's
angrist and fish
and by the way it doesn't have any
testable implication yes only Ivy model
doesn't have any testable implications
in the data under certain conditions
like if you have a binary X then it has
you can you have bounds again what I'm
the spring is that you've taken the
matter seriously you can get result that
you wouldn't do you would miss if you
know it we all know that the old
scientist if we ignore the equations of
physics if you want to walk in the dark
yes you can get by you will spend your
time going around with the lamppost
somebody will hand you a cane once in a
while so you can make a couple of more
steps but that's not science science is
putting your model explicitly and decide
and decide when you don't need a model
only by taking model seriously you learn
the condition under which you can
dispose of them from your position as an
expert on statistics I'm kind of curious
of your opinion if you have one on
efforts to popularize statistics and
models in the news media on things like
election forecasting on sites like 538
or other places who are trying to
communicate probabilities uncertainties
to the general public have you seen
those things do you have an opinion of
them I'd love to hear it
I've seen a lot of use and misuse of
statistics I think it's good to train
the public to things in terms of
uncertainty to appreciate the difficulty
of interpreting of dealing with
uncertainty but you have to keep on
telling them that statistics is a
one-dimensional universe
in a reality which is two-dimensional
actually it's two-dimensional in a
reality which is three-dimensional the
third dimension is causation is that
engine liver that you have we statistic
totally totally ignored they don't
ignore it in their guts which mean every
author of regression book have in mind
that he or she really wants answer to
causal effect question what causes what
but it's it's taboo so you cannot write
the world causation in a regression book
you just write regression and keep your
hidden desire in your guts and you you
you call it trend you don't want cause
you're cheating yourself you're writing
books your students feel that you are
not honest and when you advertise things
in the media the public feel that you're
not honest that you really are have to
ask the question that you desire to
estimate you have to ask you a question
about cause and effect so when you
advertise the study has shown studies
have shown what was the studies
well the randomized experiment if they
have a model or the ignore the model the
public will be educated eventually and
desire and demand to get no information
about the study who did it and under
what conditions have they what
guaranteed of performance of
repeatability they have the study will
be educated one of the reasons I wrote
this book is to educate the public I
call it a democratization of common
sense don't laugh
common sense is such a precious
commodity that that everybody try to
hijack and unfortunately statistics is
not completely innocent of that given
now in the area of causal influence many
people try to hijack it so that I wrote
the book the book of Y in order for
people to understand what causal
influence is about what conditions are
behind it and how not to be loathed by
various advertisements thank you thank
you you have a question right I love
questions
if you don't believe then don't talk no
no yes if we don't have any belief about
the world in which we live and the
ideally we cannot make a single step if
you don't have a CoA we've guaranteed it
I would continue to step here I would be
scared and I will just find shelter in
my cubicles
but if you are a scientist and you have
some claim and somebody actually paid
salary pays your salary so that you can
recommend something to a decision maker
then you have responsibility to tell a
decision making either fire me I have no
idea of what's going on that's one way
oh I say I'm gonna make some assumptions
but be well I give you a recommendation
it are contingent upon those assumptions
but my assumptions are reasonable
plausible the veracity of my
recommendation it's exactly the veracity
of my assumption you can take it or
leave it
but I'm giving you a tremendous amount
of information by saying that if you
believe those assumptions then my
recommendation ought to be taken
seriously as much as you believe my
assumption it's all I can say this is a
science going from assumptions to
conclusions in many cases we indeed do
not have any any knowledge about
environment we have to give I have to
admit if we three put me into archeology
and I have no idea of how to dig this
village from the right or from the left
I have no idea I had to meet fire me and
by but I don't agree people talk and
talk and talk about things that they
could have done
and this is to make assumptions because
they do have a guy get assumptions the
only difference is they don't put them
explicitly mathematically that is
unforgivable because the mathematics is
available to you today so keeping it in
your mind and doing the ordinary
correlation while keeping in your mind
and not putting explicitly it leaves you
two mistakes and two missed
opportunities so that would be all the
questions we would be able to take for
now here but please we have 10 copies of
the book of Y outside so grab your book
it's one of my favorite books so you
have to read it if you're planning to
work in AI or machine learning even if
you're not working please read the work
you're going to learn a lot a lot a lot
make it your favorite bedtime read every
day sleep with it maybe you'll be the
next person who'll be able to take us a
bit ahead on the whole revolution of
causal inference and to be able to think
about intelligence in a new way and
Judea would you be happy to take
questions on the table as well so we're
doing 10 signings right now 10 signed
copies No
would you be happy to take in questions
on the table if somebody has more
questions but person X will make person
X plus 1 wait
okay so what do the signing thank you
again
[Applause]